welcome to this video playing Aaron age
from srl ok the Benoni nagar ok let's
play and play a bit noni really there
are some funny possibilities like a form
going to a Sicilian Smith Maura that
sometimes do is just fun to play once in
a while ok I always feel tempted by this
F for business because it's so often wow
really why sense even playable and
because you can take on c3 with check
and then I'll be 50 K even here how
funny is that take on this sexy I can
take on c3 with check and then I'll be
five huh cute isn't this still is this
is not working right Queen d6 takes on
c3 e5 take six know where it's not
working well ok
I could have he could have taken there i
mean i was totally irritated by you six
which is really just bad what Bishop 24
the kind of a move is that well what
does melanie sorry I need to check on
this is totally inhuman it's not a
totally new account weird okay so we
just put the night out there huh we add
okay I mean it was playing Bishop d'fwan
it's really strange
yeah okay I'm just threatening to take
this this night if it retreats I take d6
and I really don't see what you should
do now I mean be five hmm that's really
hard to believe b5 I will just take the
form yeah or that one which looks while
Hamid castles and f7 hmm
ok that's just bishop f 79 and don't see
what he can do to prevent it after
Knight f6 there is just Bishop g5
castles 95 and he is losing with this
pin ok so let's see here I can take for
Queen g-form yeah come on let's not be
too sophisticated about it it should
release should really be enough also 95
coming
okay so rookie one then what nike fryer
maybe no root tea 194 this row cafe
Dianna winning the Queen yeah this is
this is quite ok then check once in a
while I see a tactic not not very often
but once in a while I see it I better no
prune pre-move place King e7 I shouldn't
ok i can i can play guida service
windsor look at least yes sorry if I'm
was a little bit too surprised sometimes
but as some of this move was just so
utterly strange that couldn't really
hardly believe it of course I made the
huge blunder here you can take on c3 and
on b5 I was just playing this too
quickly but TV he recaptured and then
and then I saw the whole problem I mean
I wanted to take care of course but
there was this again and this is I mean
like this even playable because of this
and ce4 we should be too will pick up
stuff in the corner ok yeah but ok I
think just Bishop c4 is good and now he
played the really really outrageous move
Bishop d4 just putting it in the middle
of the board where it is attacked
immediately I mean really strange here
white is just winning now I mean there
is really nothing that I can do to
defend this yeah take stakes and now the
check along the f alice is just it's
just dangerous just deadly
yeah rupted one and there is this new
movie I mean something like that it's
not not really helping in any way yeah
whatever we get game and lucky that that
here my super quick player making the
same same mistake that my opponents
usually do it to play too quickly Jack
here that Bishop takes you three is just
winning a piece i played this far too
far too quickly okay thanks for watching